des travaux de rénovation énergétique à
la résidence pereire à saint germain en
laye un projet lancé il ya dix ans
objectif permettre à ce bâtiment des
années 60 de respecter les normes
environnementales changement climatique
a accéléré si vous voulez la vétusté du
bâti hockey et ça a entraîné un certain
nombre de pathologies les côté cuisine
chambre ou salle de bains dans bon
nombre d'appartements deviennent de plus
en plus humide
certaines voir paraître de la moisissure
les copropriétaires ont réussi à se
mettre d'accord sur le projet coût total
des opérations un million sept cent
mille euros
face à ce type de rénovation le
gouvernement a lancé le 1er janvier ma
prime rénove copro et une aide à la
copropriété
alors que jusqu'à présent on aidait en
fonction des situations particulières
chaque copropriétaire ce qui était
beaucoup plus long là la copropriété
fait un seul dossier
on a déjà plusieurs centaines de
dossiers déposés donc ça veut dire que
c'est encourageant
emmanuelle wargon étaient sur place pour
visiter le chantier elle en a profité
pour signer un protocole avec des
professionnels de l'immobilier le but
accélérer la rénovation énergétique en
accompagnant 50000 projet sur trois ans
et cette urgence elle est aussi
dépendante d'une loi qui au 1er janvier
2000 28 interdit les locations f et g
c'est court cette période là nous nous
prenons un engagement sur trois ans
d'initier cette rénovation il y aurait
près des 5 millions de logements
qualifié de passoires thermiques donc
l'acf et j'ai en france la fin des
travaux de la résidence pereire elle est
prévue dans dix mois